the black hole is one of those movies I
always heard a lot of people talk about
but not usually very favorably and after
having finally see it I can definitely
see why it's Disney's attempt at trying
to be every popular sci-fi film that's
ever come out in fact you can point
practically scene by seeing what movie
they're trying to replicate first it's
alien then it's Belle star Galactica
that's 20,000 Leagues Under the Sea then
it's Star Wars and then finally it's
2001 the Space Odyssey
in trying to combine them all together
you get a film that has very little
identity it's just kind of a huge mess
but at the same time I can't say it was
entirely bad there are some good things
about it couple maybe it starts off with
an expedition in space where they come
across a craft that apparently has been
lost for years a scientist and his robot
standing on the edge of the black hole
he claims the rest of the crew died yeah
that's it and that he's been spending
his time trying to figure out how he can
go through the black hole and come out
the other end
he thinks he's finally found a way and
everybody's intrigued to see if he can
actually do it the downside is there's a
lot of mysterious things going on his
robot crew almost seems a little too
human and it's just this all-around
threatening tone where the people feel
more like prisoners than they do guess
secrets are discovered sides are
declared and it's a battle to see who
can get off the ship alive but this part
about the movie strangely enough is its
atmosphere and don't get me wrong a lot
of the effects are not very good they're
supposed to be flying around in space
but it just kind of looks like they're
standing around and the keying is really
really bad I mean look at that can you
take a guess where the real film is and
where the matte painting begins yeah
it's pretty painful but it almost makes
up for it with this gigantic feeling of
dread throughout the first half
everybody knows something sneaky is
going on but they can't quite put their
finger on what it is they're just
waiting for a trigger moment to whip out
their guns and start defending
themselves but there never really seems
to be a reason to plus it has maybe one
of the scariest robots of all time max
yeah doesn't sound very scary but
whenever he's on screen all the music
stops all the sound goes dead and you
just feel this thing's presence he even
gets in a few decent kills every once in
a while look at this see Jesus Christ
for Disney that's pretty gruesome for
such a simple design I love how
uncomfortable I feel whenever he's on
screen he doesn't even say anything it's
just I don't know it's just this
presence they create aside from that the
evil scientist is pretty good Ernest
Borgnine adds a little bit of comedy but
all the other actors are under this
really weird stoic way of acting and it
just comes across as so wooden even
great actors like Robbie McDowell and
Anthony Perkins you can sense they're
trying to get a good performance out of
this but there's just so little to work
with there's a lot of elements they
throw in that don't really seem to go
anywhere either
for example this woman's telepathic it's
useless there's totally no point to it
at all she communicates with the robot
at some point but what they don't have
communicators walkie-talkie cellphones
none of that is created in the future
the ending itself is just a huge
clusterfuck
it makes us in images of heaven and hell
and yeah I don't know why I don't know
what it's trying to say but it's not
quite like 2001 where the vagueness is
part of the intrigue it's more like
we're obviously trying to say something
you just can't figure out what it is
and based on the rest of the film you
can tell that whatever it had to say
probably wasn't that intelligent or
interesting look at this this incredibly
fake asteroid fields going by and one
even crashes into the ship why the hell
is it going that slowly they're whizzing
by at incredible speeds before and now
it's given time for the characters to
cross a bridge right in front of it it's
like a school crossing it just looks
ridiculous but I do give credit to the
film that it was at least trying to be a
little smarter than your average sci-fi
film yeah star wars in 2001 were big
hits and everybody was trying to copy
them and so is this film but a lot of
it's very dialogue focus not much action
not much running around I guess I kind
of like the fact that at least made an
attempt to be
smarter it just didn't seem to pay off
so yeah I guess like what a lot of
people say it's not a very good film
even by the so bad it's good standards
it's still not very good but I am glad I
saw a few of those scenes that created
some pretty decent atmosphere even if it
was really fake looking definitely not
one a Disney's best you can probably
just give it a pass